what would you do if you were the
richest person in the entire world if
you could literally buy anything
Elon musk's latest answer not new
rockets or cars or social media
improvements nope his focus is on
fighting his Target the seventh richest
man in the world Mark Zuckerberg musk
announcing on the social media platform
X formerly known as Twitter that a cage
match will be streamed on his social
media platform with the proceeds going
to Charities for veterans Zuckerberg has
yet to confirm but when first challenged
he responded on his own social media
site send me location perhaps not
coincidentally with both the social
media sites struggling analysts predict
it will have huge viewership if it
happens these guys were the platforms
they have will be able to generate
massive interest probably the most
watched fights ever in history will be
um probably dwarfing the great Rumble in
the Jungle between Muhammad Ali and
George Foreman so why the intense
rivalry it started when Facebook lost a
satellite on a held SpaceX launch owned
by musk later fights over artificial
intelligence and then Zuckerberg
launched threads called a Twitter killer
with one of his employees saying it
would be run sanely and apparent dig at
musk's erratic leadership style that's
when the tough talk began
so now a possible fight in one corner a
39 year old billionaire
trained in Jiu Jitsu in the other a 52
year old billionaire who says he's been
lifting weights this is me curling of
45. oh my gosh oh Zuckerberg all day the
fact that he's training Jiu Jitsu you
know Jiu Jitsu is like the cheat codes
to fighting basically if you know Jiu
Jitsu and you're the guy doesn't then
you've got a huge huge Advantage we've
seen musk's dance moves maybe about to
find out if he can move any better in
the cage Patty culhane Al Jazeera
sir